on this episode of stack chat Spotify
infrastructure engineer Matt Brown talks
about how his team approached the move
to Google Cloud and kubernetes thanks
for trying to be Matt so I want you to
tell me at first just how is Spotify
using GCP behind the scenes a little bit
so Spotify we use what feels like every
part of GCP and some area of Spotify and
we've moved over the past couple years
really everything we do to GCP so we use
products on the data side BigTable cloud
SQL bigquery pub/sub for many things the
area that I work in which is
infrastructure for a back-end services
historically we use a lot of Google
compute engine but that's moving mostly
over to kubernetes engine now and then
you had to choose between kubernetes and
managed kubernetes on GCP so well how
did that choice play out for you
so really as we were starting to think
and plan for when do we want to move to
kubernetes we were already moving that
way from having our own data centers to
running pretty much everything in Google
cloud so the idea of setting up our own
kubernetes cluster is learning how to
manage the networking all of those
things just never really sounded very
appealing to us the big promise for
Google cloud for us is all of the
managed services we can use and then our
engineers can kind of move up a layer
and what we're worrying about and not
worrying about the littler things so
much so a manage servers like gke was
really perfect for us so what other
kinds of benefits did your engineering
teams get then from making that shift so
a huge one is that in our current
platform of Helios it's not very easy to
do auto scaling so teams tend to have to
do capacity playing every once in a
while figure out how many virtual
machines would they need for peat
traffic something like that and then as
a result we are most teams are over
provisioned for a large amount of the
time so auto scaling helps a lot with
that because not only can they respond
to shifts in traffic a lot more faster
but they also just don't have to be over
provisioning and using so many resources
as you're making this transition how
does this system handle failure or
degradation of any of the infrastructure
or pieces so we use regional clusters in
GK's so we can be deployed across many
zones
Spotify runs across
three different regions in GCP so we're
kind of just relying on those primitives
in a way for that type of reliability
and then we also as an infrastructure to
even do a lot of practicing around let's
think of a possible disaster
somebody deleting a cluster in the cloud
console an accident let's say let's
practice those things to make sure we
have good play books we know how to
recover or we can catch those with
alerts because we figure eventually it's
gonna happen in production anyway so why
not give us a chance to practice it are
there other things that you could have
done or encouraged others to do that
would have sped up this change I would
say one thing that we found out and
doing this going through this whole
process so we were a little bit
pleasantly surprised that is we didn't
have to do as much evangelizing or
motivation or having like a carryin
stick to tell people you need to move to
Cooper Nettie's most engineering teams
are really excited and one thing that we
found worked the best was we had a group
of engineers who weren't on the
infrastructure team they were just early
adopters and they did a lot of working
and talking to other engineers writing
blog posts giving talks in an internal
conference we have to motivate other
people so one thing that I think we
could have done a little bit more of was
just trying to build more of those sort
of like champions or evangelist it was a
really pleasant surprise but we could
have always had more awesome it sounds
like you're on the way and I look
forward to hearing more about it as you
get closer and closer to your goal
thanks very much for joining me today
thanks for having me if you enjoyed this
episode
check out the stack jet playlist for
more videos
you